UFC is what UFC is because of Dana White
Dana has made it about the sport he
never made it about the fight he never
made it about one fighter he is very
quick to call out anybody it doesn't
matter if it's the number one guy in the
league he'll call him out Jon Jones
he'll call out Connor if he screws up
but he'll back him up to the highest
level he'll say that was some stupid he
did he'll sit there and straight up tell
you what he likes what he doesn't like
everybody learned during covid he was
the number one commissioner in all of
sports every commissioner in America
caved NBA caved NFL caved MLB caved
every commissioner caved except for one
guy who had brass balls called Dana
White who said I don't give a we're
going to find a place to do the fight so
during Co that's the only sport the
world watched we watched UFC he's a
wartime uh leader as well as a peacetime
leader Dana in in a past life could have
been a gangster maybe he was but he
could have been a gangster he could have
ran a family you either are that guy
you're not that guy that's how Dana is